welcome to this video maradona let's do
something else let's play the tango yeah
this guy is probably just transposing to
the classical anyway yeah and we have
the Zurich variation it's not much that
I can do after the tingle here to avoid
that I had the same against him earlier
he was one of the brave souls who
grabbed the pawn I had a totally winning
position and he's doing it again I don't
understand them I do it I mean he really
was completely busted in this game then
he had earlier against me and now he's
doing this okay it's also not really
great to be perfectly honest but this is
a kind of a try of an improvement yeah
this is some something I mean you really
have to be I don't know how to call it
to me yeah to grab this kind of kind of
porn and try to hold on it's just a very
very anesthetic way to play em get
nothing developed but okay is um not
like it's losing immediately okay can go
here so matter of taste I can also play
Luke the aid or 94 yeah maybe start with
this yeah blacks compensation is the
better development and the nice squares
yeah we like to see 5 or hear you form
and it's not so clear how wide is some
go into going to to untangle here can
just take it if I want
maybe he's threatening threatening black
Bishop g7 and not really it's not really
a threat can go f6 for example or root
d8 first then you might take them and
this is a case where I really have a
tattoo too much of good continuations
that look somewhat interesting hard to
determine what's best I don't know I
really don't know him he may be can take
a five but is not not considering it
seriously it seems maybe I could have
taken a five I wasn't sure
Bishop age three Bishop of Bishop e3
Bishop f3 interesting camp hard to tell
I really this is the kind of position
where a player like I am I'm not such a
quick calculator and it I usually need a
little bit of time to figure out really
what's best if it's so concrete like
here and I just have to go with with my
feeling here with Rupert e6 Luke d6 will
go over to g6 or h6 it definitely is a
good attack but I wasn't able to
determine if this was really the the
best continuation so Luke age 3 was what
I was thinking
can also move the bishop but it doesn't
look right g6 he will really take this
is not not enough I can just drop it
back to ca then this is not ridiculous
Bishop look age 6 I think you can take
the bishop I don't see a wind there
takes rook takes Bishop g2 it's probably
no win okay I'm going back which doesn't
look right but maybe it's it's what I
need to do maybe I should have gone to
f5 yeah there wasn't it wasn't really a
reason to go to see aid we're okay the
idea is simply look at age six queen age
four and made here i am here's here's a
case where the bishop on fif would be a
would be would have been better would be
just covering you form a little bit
better if it takes you for now queen ah4
isn't this good Queen edge form how does
he cover h2 with Bishop b5
I would have been much better they have
the bishop on f5 so that I am not
immediately checkmated young really
would have been much much better now
rook the eight made us a constant
problem
yeah it is just this is a kind of the
annoying the type of very annoying loss
where you know that you had a fantastic
position but you screwed it up with all
the pieces in the attack maybe just
Bishop f5 was enough not sure this is
something that is of course very
dependent on the concrete moves that
have to be rechecked afterwards with the
with the comp yeah they have to cover
the aid unfortunately you can even go
rook g1 now besides the problem that I
have no time no time at all yeah in Rupp
the aid yeah I just Bishop to a5 how we
got again black resigns yeah I just
that's a frustrating kind of loss okay
let's let's have a look and see how I
could have played this better ok well
the computer is saying why does better
so it's probably not completely
completely sound attack but I mean they
can come on I mean this was definitely
bad I have to go to a five-year just
said that my that the night is at least
protected mmm but still the concepts
white can defend one key ideas Bishop f5
it looks dangerous it still does my okay
possible if he gets in this is a very
important resource yeah if he gets us in
I thought it was too much on the King
already but this is maybe not the case
then
yeah him here there are many ideas maybe
I made a wrong a wrong decision here I
don't know what what exactly is in my my
analysis here maybe also 94 possible 94s
also also always an idea which is a
little bit different than bishop e6
first but maybe I should have shouldn't
have played Queenie 7 I was thinking
about this which is not terribly bad but
maybe I should go to e4 immediately this
is maybe better it gives this
opportunity and I can go to g5 in one go
where it's probably a little bit better
I mean black has a compensation here
that's not really the question but
probably I made mistake somewhere here
and 96 is also interesting attacking the
pawn but the way it went I guess really
was good for wide young mm-hmm he I have
to do some things that don't help should
you form yeah this is this is losing due
to due to Bishop g7 or here check this
parrado and then this same this is the
key point that this Bishop is helping
out in the defense and T I'm really just
lost him yeah not much that I can do
here I mean I'm not so losing on time
but the position is also completely lost
so I didn't play it precisely after he
grabbed the pawn I always get very
optimistic when they do this because I
simply think this is a crab line for
white I mean you don't develop anything
and so on this is not really what I like
me but punishing it is this is another
thing if you have limited time and still
have to be a precise maybe 94 is better
I forgot what exactly i had analyzed him
maybe nighty for me at least a little
bit better
if I now know that I look at it maybe I
have to go there anyway maybe maybe this
is the better move that's when Jeff's
you have compensation in many ways but
it's still a question of being precise i
know that Mandela's they ended in some
kind of weird to draw by repetition this
is what I remember the computer here if
you give it a 22 stockfish it says 0 0 0
which is it not much help okay thanks
for watching